écoutez j'ai vu de voir que ça
passionnait pas les foules 1,55 pour 20
contre sur 577 députés
faible mobilisation non saint-ex bidon
et je pense qu'au sénat je suis même pas
sûr que on examine ce texte en tous les
cas moi je proposais à mon groupe j'en
ai parlé avec eux catherine morin
desailly qui préside la commission de la
culture et qui examine ce texte qui
regarde ça avec beaucoup de réserve
si on va aller jusqu'au bout de la
discussion parce que ce texte est pas au
point
on voit bien qu'ils appellent beaucoup
d'interrogations et en tous les cas pour
ce qui est de mon groupe je ne suis pas
sûr que on ne propose pas de refuser de
le discuter parce que on va pas perdre
de temps
discuter d'un texte qui est pas au point
et qui ne peut-être de bon pour de bon
diagnostic
encore une fois il ya un sujet
maintenant les réponses qui sont
apportées sont pas au niveau et chacun
l'a dit est ce qu'il n'ya pas même un
risque d'effets pervers de la loi qui
pourrait même légitimer une fausse
information si le fameux juge des
référés qui ne disposera que de 48
heures ne trouve pas les éléments pour
l'interdire et puis il va y avoir des
référés en pagaille
on va arriver à une thrombose du référé
sur ces sujets là tout le monde va
vouloir faire des référés effectivement
le revers de la médaille c'est que si
vous obtenez pas satisfaction
on va donner le sentiment que ce qui est
écrit ou dit est vrai sans préjudice des
autres observations celle de de mon
collègue monsieur mélenchon évidemment
est pas dénuée de pertinence de quel
droit le csa qui est une autorité
administrative peut prendre des
décisions à caractère politique bon on
avisera au point on a bien compris votre
position et enfin marseille va
maintenant passer à la partie politique
de